has anyone ever told you that you need
to have a clear goal in order to achieve
something or get better
according to modern learning science the
opposite is true for example the best
surfers and not those that train to win
a prize or to be featured in a glossy
magazine but those that play with the
waves every day because they love it
this technique argues that you get
better at something focus on the process
of learning and not the outcome a
product too far away to motivate you in
a Stanford University design experiment
a pottery teacher split the class into
two groups the first group focused on
making as many clay pots as they wanted
the second on making one single very
beautiful pot at the end the teacher
graded the pods and announced a winner
the results were clear all the best
parts came from students that made many
pots not those that tried making one
single winning piece of art to optimize
process learning set a fix study time in
which you focus on the material for say
25 minutes a day in that time don't try
to reach a certain goal like reading an
entire chapter just learn for the exact
amount of time that you set yourself
then stop process learning will help you
feel more relaxed during your study and
give you a sense of accomplishment once
you are done the very fact that you were
interrupted in the middle of your
practice before reaching a milestone
keeps interest up and increases the
motivation to continue the next day to
maximize process learning watch our
general learning tips please let us know
what you think about this learning
technique by living a comment in the
section below for more techniques visit
us on facebook youtube or at sprouts
schools calm